مع اخر دفعه من نتائج ولايه اريزونا توقع
حتى وكاله اساسيه براس ووسائل اعلام
امريكيه فوز السناطر الديمقراطيين مايكل
على منافسه الجمهوري بلاك ماستر ليحافظ
كلي على مقعده في مجلس الشيوخ ويرسم مسارا
للديمقراطيين للحفاظ على اغلبيتهم في
المجلس كليبي دوره اصدر بيانا شكر فيه
سكان اريزونا لوضعه ثقتهم به طبعا عمليات
الفرز لم تنتهي هنا في هذه المقاطعه هناك
نحو
200.000 قسيمه اقتراح ما زالت قيد
الاحتساب ولكن وفق الدفع الاخيره من الصعب
على ماسترز ان يتغلب على كلي وان يلحق به
حتى هذه اللحظه هناك اصوات جمهوريه في هذه
الولايه ما زالت تنتقد المسؤولين
الانتخابيين هنا لتاخرها في عمليات
الاحتساب واعلان النتائج المسؤولون
الانتخابيون بدورهم يردون على ان هذه
الانتقادات ليست في محلها رجب تخفيف حده
الخطاب ايضا الاجراءات الامنيه ما زالت
مشدده هنا في محيط مركز الفرز الرئيسي في
هذه المقاطعه تحسبا لمظاهرات بالنسبه
لسباق المتعلق بمنصب حاكمه الولايه حققت
ايضا كيتي هابز الديمقراطيه المرشحه لهذا
المنصب تقدما على منافستها الجمهوريه كاري
ليك رغم ان هذه الدفعه الاخيره من القسائم
التي اعلن عنها كان من المتوقع ان تصب
اكثر في مصلحه الجمهوريين خصوصا انها كانت
من قسائم الاقتراع المبكر التي سلمت يوم
التصويت